Los Johns no encajan en estereotipos definidos.
Pero hay una verdad universal:
si no hay John, no hay comprador y no hay víctima.
Por ello, si queremos empezar a atacar el tráfico sexual,
hay que empezar por John.
Y las empresas pueden hacerlo mientras John está en su trabajo.
Existe una organización llamada "Empresas por el fin de la esclavitud y el tráfico"
cuya sigla en inglés es BEST.
Cuando comenzaron a trabajar en 2012,
hicieron un estudio sobre los Johns de Seattle.
¿Saben qué descubrieron?
Los Johns son hombres comunes, que trabajan en negocios del lugar.
Sus edades oscilan entre 18 y 84.
Son padres de familia.
Admiten que consumen sexo cuando viajan por negocios,
cuando asisten a eventos deportivos
o cuando prestan servicio en el ejército.
Pero esta es la sorpresa:
el estudio realizado por BEST reveló que la compra de sexo vía web
llega a su pico a las 2 de la tarde.
Esto significa que los Johns tienden a comprar sexo a mitad del día laboral.
Creo que hay una manera de impedir a los Johns comprar sexo
en medio de la jornada laboral.
Y las empresas pueden lograrlo de tres maneras muy sencillas.
Primero, imponiendo una política
que establezca claramente
que la empresa prohíbe comprar sexo durante la jornada laboral,
sea usando los recursos de la empresa o durante las horas de trabajo.
Sí, es así.
Estoy diciendo que el manual debe dar un ejemplo específico
que prohíba la compra de sexo durante los viajes laborales,
en las ferias internacionales, que es donde esto sucede.
Ahora bien, las políticas deben también ser aplicadas y comunicadas.
Varios estudios sobre el tema han demostrado
que la mejor manera de disuadir a los Johns
es con la humillación pública y la vergüenza.
De este modo, las empresas que detectan a un John en el acto de comprar sexo
a través de los equipos o los recursos de la empresa,
y aun sí lo dejan pasar, lo esconden bajo la alfombra y no los despiden,
son cómplices de estimular la demanda.
Implementar una política es una de las mejores formas de empezar.
La segunda es educar al personal.
Las empresas pueden hacer mucho con solo capacitar a su personal
sobre las señales y banderas rojas que alertan sobre la trata de personas.
Fue en este momento cuando pensé cómo mi empresa podía marcar la diferencia.
En nuestro país, las autopistas, los aeropuertos y las paradas de camiones
se usan, literalmente, como rutas de esclavitud moderna.
Nuestra empresa emplea más de 100 000 conductores
distribuidos en todo el país y en todo el mundo.
De manera que era totalmente lógico enseñarles a detectar esas banderas rojas.
La idea no es que tan solo miren y hagan las cosas por su cuenta,
sino que llamen a un número particular, la línea de emergencia,
y dar lugar a que la ley intervenga.
Con este objetivo, nos unimos
a una organización de camioneros contra el tráfico de personas.
Esta organización, con base en Colorado, tenía soporte en la web y material
que se entregaba a los camioneros
con todo lo necesario para que puedan detectar esas banderas rojas.
Por ejemplo, oír conversaciones radiales de chicas en salidas de rutas cercanas.
O ver mujeres menores de edad que salen de vehículos
en el estacionamiento de camiones.
Cuando lanzamos esta capacitación,
algunos camioneros tuvieron la valentía de admitir que habían visto a estas chicas
golpeando a la ventanilla de los camiones en busca de clientes.
Decían que ellos no compraban.
Pero tampoco sabían lo suficiente como para hacer una llamada.
Y eso es lo que pretendemos que hagan.
Esta organización, "Camioneros contra el tráfico de personas", o TAT,
también subraya la necesidad de que los hombres hablen entre sí
sobre la compra de sexo vía web y la importancia de no consumirlo.
Se muestran hombres uniformados orgullosos por no consumir.
Si queremos un cambio cultural de esta atrocidad,
es necesario que los hombres hablen con otros hombres
sobre las causas ocultas que estimulan la demanda.
Porque a veces los Johns desconocen
que están comprando chicas que son sometidas a esclavitud.
Esto me lleva a la última manera en que las empresas pueden ayudar.
Todas las empresas tienen algún recurso especial
o alguna receta secreta que pueden aplicar
para combatir la trata de personas.
Por ejemplo, Visa, Master Card y American Express
no procesan transacciones procedentes de backpage.com,
un sitio de sexo en la web que vendía sexo comercial,
con una recaudación de 9 millones de dólares al mes.
En abril de 2018, backpage.com y los sitios vinculados fueron cerrados,
y el FBI confiscó todos sus bienes.
Emplear a sobrevivientes es otra manera en que las empresas pueden ayudar.
Randstad, una organización que trabaja con empresas
para buscar sobrevivientes que necesitan un buen empleo,
cuenta con un excelente programa llamado "Hire Hope".
Es un programa que hemos usado y sabemos que funciona.
Además de capacitar a sus auxiliares de vuelo
y a la tripulación,
Delta Air Lines también ofrece SkyMiles, mediante un programa llamado "SkyWish"
para ayudar a los sobrevivientes a escapar de sus traficantes
y a reunirse con sus familias.
Hay miles de cosas que las empresas pueden hacer.
Solo deben decidir qué medidas tomar para unirse a la lucha.
Hoy en día, nadie puede justificar la esclavitud.
Pero considero que es una de las mayores atrocidades
en materia de derechos civiles de nuestra época.
Por fortuna, la comunidad empresarial está en una posición privilegiada
para capacitar a sus empleados,
aplicar políticas
y usar sus recursos especiales
para combatir el tráfico de personas.
Y ¿qué pueden hacer Uds.?
¿Qué tal si empiezan a reconocer las banderas rojas?
¿Qué tal si empiezan a observar todas las señales que hay alrededor
y hacen una llamada?
No se sanciona a quien llama para hacer una denuncia
cuando ven algo fuera de lugar.
Juntos podemos proteger a nuestros hijos,
podemos educar al personal de trabajo que tenemos cerca
y lograr una sociedad mejor,
en la que todos podamos vivir y trabajar con John.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)